it depends there is no one best way but
what we do know is that most folks
overwhelmingly think that the right
answer that question is that he who
speaks first or she who speaks first is
lost and that is not the right answer
it depends on where you get the biggest
bang for your effort because when you
make an offer you get the benefit of
anchoring your counterpart setting a
starting point to which they must
respond if you receive the first offer
you get the benefit of the information
and so you're in an information
advantage position so the question is
which of those two in the particular
negotiation you're facing is going to be
more powerful where is the benefit is
the benefit from setting the anchor or
is the benefit from getting the
information one piece of the answer to
that is how prepared are you for the
negotiation and another important piece
is how prepared is your counterpart
because that will begin to give you
insight into which of the strategies is
the right one for a particular
negotiation
in the course of the negotiation you're
going to be trading proposals back and
forth your counterpart is gonna want to
go issue by issue this is such a common
belief right we even have a name for it
solve the easy issues first this is a
bad idea it appears at first that it
might be good right you solve the easy
issues now there's a commitment that
each of you has so it's harder to walk
away but if you solve all the easy
issues what's left the really ugly
800-pound gorilla in the room and you
have nothing left to trade but there's
something even more insidious than that
solve the easy issues first assumes that
you're easy issues are my easy issues
what if they're not what if my easy
issue turns out to be a really important
and critical issue for you and because
I'm using that simple rule solve the
easy issues first we get agreement on
that issue
I've lost a degree of freedom I've lost
the capacity to use that concession to
get something that I care about and that
is a real failure on my part what's
going to happen in negotiation is I want
you to focus on negotiating at the
package level not at the issue level and
then once you have that package what's
going to happen is your counterparts are
going to try to break it apart to go
issue by issue you need to resist that
in fact one way to do that is to keep
talking about the issues as a package
and then use what I call yoking language
if this happens if I make a concession
here then I get this concession here you
keep trying to bring it back to the
package level because your counterparts
will try because they believe it's
easier to negotiate issue by issue if
you negotiate issue by issue you have a
series of battles and everybody is
keeping score if you negotiate at the
package level
it's a proposal that we can craft to
make us both better off to find that
solution space where I'm better off and
your whole or better off but it's the
package that does that otherwise we're
just going through one battle after
another one of the most important things
that you can figure out is when should
you walk away
most folks go into a negotiation and do
not have a clear idea about when the
deal moves from being a deal they could
consider - when the deal becomes one
they should run from and that's what
preparation is really about so you need
to know what your alternatives are what
happens to you if there were no
agreement what's your bottom line what's
the point of indifference between saying
yes and walking away and then something
that most people don't think about
what's your aspiration what is an
optimistic assessment of what you could
achieve in this negotiation and that is
so important and so many people don't
even consider what's possible